[Musica]
[Applauso]
chi di voi ha visitato il museo negli
ultimi 12 mesi
ma siete parecchi chi ha pianificato la
visita facendo una ricerca sul web ma
siete parecchi anche lui anche questi e
chi ha trovato subito quello che cercava
pochi lo sospettavo io di solito faccio
così digito su google e il nome del
museo che voglio visitare che di solito
non trovo mai al primo colpo il sito
ufficiale
a volte non lo trovo proprio se voglio
invece visitare una città d'arte
cominciò una ricerca che può durare
delle ore a volte anche dei giorni
perché con l'arte si fa fatica a certe
volte a trovare le informazioni come
quella volta che ho portato le mie
figlie a firenze prima di partire
abbiamo pianificato la visita siamo
andati in rete abbiamo cercato
informazioni sui musei sui capolavori da
vedere sulle piazze da visitare
e a quel punto dopo dieci minuti e loro
mi hanno abbandonata
mi hanno lasciata lì da sola e sono
rimasta lì sola a navigare in internet
per due giorni sono riemersa però
vincitrice stanca ma vincitrice avevo in
una mano
un itinerario di massima e nell'altra
avevo la prenotazione per entrare in un
museo visitare un museo una città d'arte
può essere faticoso sin da quando si
cercano le informazioni online e il web
ei social non ha cambiato le nostre
abitudini hanno cambiato il modo con cui
noi cerchiamo le informazioni
pianifichiamo i nostri viaggi e
scegliamo che cosa vedere e cosa
tralasciare e voi lo sapete che a
castelfranco c'è un capolavoro
meravigliosa a pochi passi da qui è la
pala di castelfranco di giorgione si
trova nel duomo
chi di voi l'ha vista
chi non ha alzato la mano deve rimediare
immediatamente perché l'arte che non si
fa trovare rischia di essere dimenticata
l'arte che non comunica bene in modo
efficace e rischia di essere anche un po
noiosa ancora prima che il viaggio di
scoperta si è iniziato e fondamentale
allora per chi si occupa di arte e
cultura iniziare a comunicare in modo
nuovo per che cercando le informazioni
su internet quando le troviamo capita
magari spesso di trovare testi lunghi
chilometri iscritti fitti fitti e con
paroloni complicati come capi muliebri
quando mi trovo davanti a queste due
parole di solito io mi sento sempre un
pochino disagio e mi domando ma perché
per raccontarmi e spiegarmi un'opera
d'arte dovevi scrivere capi muliebri e
non teste di donna era più semplice
l'arte deve comunicare bene deve farsi
capire avere un linguaggio accessibile
il linguaggio che usiamo noi tutti i
giorni del xxi secolo e deve smetterla
di rivolgersi ai pochi eletti a quelli
che i capi muliebri sanno cosa sono
e voi che non lo sapevate vi sentite un
pochino in colpa adesso forse ma adesso
lo sapete quindi l'arte ha tutti gli
strumenti per comunicare bene a il web
ei social
e a noi noi i visitatori che non
sappiamo resistere davanti a un
capolavoro meraviglioso e dobbiamo
tirare fuori lo smartphone e fare la
foto fare il self i e postarlo
condividerlo raccontarlo
l'arte deve comunicare in modo efficace
e invece la situazione al momento è
frammentata
la situazione al momento online è un po
caotica
secondo uno studio compiuto dall
osservatorio del politecnico di milano
qualche tempo fa soltanto il 52 per
cento dei musei italiani e social
e solo il 13 per cento è presente sulle
tre piattaforme social più diffuse in
facebook
instagram e twitter il 57 per cento dei
musei italiani a un sito internet poco
più della metà
quindi se non lo trovate su google
forse perché non c'è e tra i musei che
un sito non ce l'hanno
hanno però il 10 per cento ha però la
pagina facebook quindi se non lo trovate
su google forse la trovate su facebook
l'arte deve iniziare a comunicare in
modo efficace a farlo con gli strumenti
contemporanei
per fare cosa poi per aumentare il
numero dei visitatori
no l'obiettivo non è quello non è
strappare biglietti per riempire ancora
di più i nostri musei per portare ancora
più visitatori nelle nostre città d'arte
l'obiettivo non è usare i social per
aumentare i visitatori reali ma per
aumentare il traffico virtuale
questo me l'ha detto la responsabile
marketing di un museo spagnolo di madrid
che sa usare molto bene il web ei social
o pubblicato l'intervista che mi ha
rilasciato sul mio blog nella quale mi
ha anche detto che non esiste differenza
tra visitatori e reale e virtuale perché
sono la stessa identica cosa è che la
grande rivoluzione di internet è la
condivisione della conoscenza e la
diffusione delle opere d'arte delle
collezioni d'arte in tutto il mondo
e allora ciò significa che è possibile
che chi non verrà mai a castelfranco
veneto possa conoscere la palla del
giorgione condividerla in tutto il mondo
contribuendo la sua continua scoperta e
allora bisogna veramente iniziare a
comunicare l'arte in modo efficace è
necessario che chi si occupa di arte
cultura inizi subito si crei degli
alleati
e chi sono questi alleati e visitati
duri i blogger blogger
già immagino le facce inorridite dei
puristi dell'arte di quelli che l'arte è
una cosa seria e mi che lavoreremo
lasciare in mano un blogger a queste
persone dico che il blogger è un
visitatore molto speciale è un
visitatore che sa usare i nuovi mezzi di
comunicazione sa come diffondere le
informazioni sa come parlare a tutti gli
altri visitatori
perché ha un linguaggio accessibile
l'altro grande alleato sono i visitatori
siete voi voi che avete la capacità e la
voglia di condividere tutto quello che
vedete quando vi trovate in una città
d'arte voi che avete la capacità di
raccontare un museo un capolavoro in un
modo in cui nessun ente del turismo e
nessun museo potrà mai fare perché la
vostra esperienza
vale molto di più di qualsiasi altro
racconto calato dall'alto
in gioco c'è la capacità di calare
l'arte in un mondo reale che mette il
visitatore al centro di tutto sono
moltissime le città nel mondo
e i musei più importanti che hanno già
iniziato che hanno iniziato a farsi
alleati i visitatori ei blogger perché
la posta in gioco è alta e allora io ho
iniziato oggi ho postato sui miei canali
social il capolavoro che questa città
custodisce e voi siete pronti a
diffonderlo in tutto il mondo
[Applauso]